[Musique]
hier sur notre plateau nous recevions
pierre et Maryse un couple de retraités
parti plusieurs mois en vacances avec
leur camping-car c'est magnifique un
appareil pareil mais c'est magnifique
quand nous partez en vacances
il constate que la locataire qui occupé
leur maison refuse de quitter les lieux
il a fallu qu'on paye l'eau à sa place
les trois derniers mois ne payent même
plus loyer depuis plus de 2 ans ils sont
donc obligés de vivre dans leur
camping-car de 10 mètres carrés et
déclare aujourd'hui les travaux on a
permis de rien elle me brûle en notre
vie je suis pas bien je suis pas bien on
a plus de vie mais de son côté
l'occupant de leur logement affirme
vivre un enfer et dénonce un acharnement
médiatique alors retraité en camping-car
le droit de réponse de l'occupant
illégal dans TPMP
on aura je vous dis ces audios dans un
instant elle s'appelle Nadia cette
occupante illégal du logement du groupe
de retraités à Marseille juste avant
romain rossillandi merci d'être là vous
êtes à vos cas spécialisé en droit
immobilier alors il faut pas parler de
squatteuse au sujet de Nadia non pas du
tout en fait c'est une ancienne
locataire qui a vu son bail résilier par
le tribunal car donner son expulsion et
qui se maintient abusivement dans les
lieux à l'expiration de son bail et
malgré un jugement d'expulsion une
décision de justice qui est définitive
qui a ordonné son expulsion donc c'est
pas un squatteur un squatteur c'est
quelqu'un qui rentre chez vous en
changeant les serrures par les fractions
manœuvre violence ou contrainte c'est
pas du tout le cas donc c'est quand même
important de le préciser moi ça me
choque toujours quand je vois ses
affaires quand on parle de squat en
squat c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui
rentre chez vous pareil fraction et elle
c'est différent alors la situation
aujourd'hui elle est choquante pour le
propriétaire moi je me batte depuis 20
ans pour défendre
vous allez écouter la réponse de Nadia
dans un instant et si vous voulez pour
le propriétaire c'est le même combat en
fait vous soyez victime de squats ou
d'un locataire peut SCR jeu qui paient
pas ses loyers c'est un parcours du
combattant pour arriver à obtenir son
expulsion Manu militariste il est
d'abord il y a la procédure judiciaire
qui dure en moyenne un an et demi deux
ans et ça peut être encore parfois
beaucoup plus long et ensuite on se bat
contre l'État contre le préfet qui doit
accorder le concours de la force
publique et c'est dans ce dossier c'est
ce qui se passe en fait c'est pour ça
que c'est pauvre Jean sont obligés de
vivre dans un camping-car parce que le
préfet des Bouches-du-Rhône n'exécute
pas une édition de justice d'accord donc
l'État lui-même pour plein de raisons il
y a plein de bonnes raisons ou mauvaises
qui peuvent conduire le préfet à pas
accorder la force publique vous allez
vous allez entendre la réaction Nadia
dans un sens juste avant
on pouvait revoir cet extrait de pierre
et Maryse qui sont venus nous raconter
leur calvaire Mathieu je sais pas si tu
as vu ça mais tu étais peut-être à
Santorin mais tu vas avoir ça regardez
quand vous vivez dedans quand vous avez
passé deux confinement là deux ans et
demi là croyez moi c'est pas il paraît
que c'est extrêmement froid pour vous
l'hiver pour Maryse c'est froid l'hiver
c'est très chaud l'été tous les jours ça
coûte du fric vous pouvez pas vous garer
vous voulez avec un truc comme ça c'est
entre 15 et 20 euros tous les jours tous
les jours tous les jours il a été opéré
deux fois du coeur il y a eu un cancer
de la vessie tu sais tu dépressives je
suis supposable je ne peux plus je suis
toujours en train de pleurer là j'ai pas
eu des médicaments pour pas pleurer mais
des je suis pas bien je suis pas bien
on a plus de vie
alors ça leur pourrit la vie aujourd'hui
sachez que voilà on l'a vu et vous
l'avez vu un Maryse elle est sous
antidépresseur on l'a vu hier elle est
vraiment
j'en ai parlé avec elle après l'émission
elle ne vit plus c'est vraiment je vous
dis il va y avoir un drame parce que
hier aussi il a des gros problèmes de
santé et que ça le ronge tous les jours
c'est c'est vraiment ça il y a un enfer
aujourd'hui nous allons entendre la
réponse de Nadia et vous allez avoir ces
réponses puisque hier ils en veulent
forcément beaucoup à Nadia donc cette
occupante on dit occupant illégal
occupante s'envoi du titre voilà c'est
ça d'accord regardez
on a la procédure on a essayé de trouver
un arrangement actuel elle ne veut
absolument rien savoir le problème c'est
qu'on ne sait pas pourquoi alors le
prolonge chaque fois là pour la
traversée
le profite de toutes les fissures de la
loi française
juridique quand il a fallu partir
fallait partir d'accord donc il a fallu
maintenant ici pour les constater le
fait et quand celui-ci s'est présenté
dans la même power la porte et depuis ce
jour-là le fil forcé c'est-à-dire le
prend aucune lettre recommandée elle ne
voit pas la porte elle ne payait plus
l'eau il a fallu qu'on paye l'eau à sa
place on a plus envie de rien elle nous
brûle notre vie alors
pourquoi on peut pas expulser facilement
des occupants illégaux c'est ça que je
comprends pas moi premièrement la
procédure judiciaire beaucoup trop
longue donc ça c'est un problème général
de la justice en France c'est pas normal
d'attendre 18 mois pour avoir une
décision de justice qui leur donne
l'expulsion deuxième délai c'est la
préfecture j'ai des dossiers parce que
ça ce dossier là il faut pas croire
qu'il est isolé je suis content que vous
donniez la parole aux propriétaires moi
mon cabinet j'ai des dizaines
avoir des dizaines il va y avoir des
centaines bah j'espère que j'espère
qu'on les metières on va faire pareil
évidemment vous pourrez pas médiatiser
tous les dossiers là il y a donc ça
choque l'opinion mais les dossiers comme
ça moi j'ai un client là qui est rentré
qui est arrivé au cabinet la semaine
dernière à Créteil Val-de-Marne 50000 €
derrière et loyer décision d'expulsion
en 2018 2018 a eu le covid il y a eu
vous savez il y avait la traversée 12
mois sur 12 bref en 2022 il y a toujours
pas d'expulsion il est il touche pas un
centime donc depuis 20 ans moi j'essaye
de faire entendre dans les tribunaux à
mon niveau la voix des propriétaires
parce que tout le procès est
déséquilibré le procès se fait autour de
la personne de l'occupant il y a une
enquête sociale il y a la CAPEX la
commission de prévention des expulsions
mais la situation du propriétaire
m'intéresse absolument personne et je
communique moi au débat je dis au
magistrat mais attendez mon client voilà
il est propriétaire
il y a des mecs qui passent toutes leurs
vies pour ça c'est voilà c'est le projet
de leur vie on l'a vu un pierre et
Maryse ils ont pas d'autre chose ils ont
voilà c'était le projet de leur vie
c'était le investissement de leur vie
ils se retrouvent à la rue dans un
camping-car alors vous allez entendre
juste après vous allez entendre les
réaction de Nadia donc la locataire
l'occupant de Delphine je voulais dire
un truc déjà le principe de la trêve
hivernale moi je trouve que c'est une
aberration aujourd'hui parce que il y a
des associations qui existent pour ça
quand on ne peut plus se loger et au
final c'est très hivernale elle met
toujours dans la merde les proprio qui
effectivement les gens qui sont censés
être blindés
là c'est la trêve hivernale qui pose
problème en l'occurrence c'est le c'est
à partir du 31 octobre
parce que dans ce dossier là si la
préfecture de ne pas son feu vert avant
le 31 octobre clairement elle va gagner
6 mois de cuisson
ça c'est le préfet c'est à lui de
décider mais
elle a été supprimé pour les squatteurs
donc les gens qui rentrent chez vous par
effraction
c'est la même chose c'est incroyable de
devoir jouer des locataires donc je suis
pas d'accord avec vous la traversale
dans plein de cas mais ça peut se
justifier la même chose c'est quelque
chose de d'horrible financièrement
moralement même au niveau de la santé
pour ces gens-là qui travaillent leur
vie mais alors il faut savoir quelque
chose qu'on dit pas aussi les gens
profite aujourd'hui pour le dire les
propriétaires qui ont un refus de
concours de force publique en le préfère
refuse exister une décision de justice
peuvent se retourner contre l'État mais
ça prend combien de temps ça ira ça ça
fonctionne bien et on obtient une
indemnité ils doivent prendre leur
douche dans un
camping-cars la santé de la réalité bien
sûr
on va écouter la réaction de Nadia qu'on
a eu l'occupant illégale du logement de
couple retraités à Marseille Mathieu si
vous voulez dire juste une regarde la
seule question pour moi aujourd'hui
c'est pas très bien ça c'est le préfet
si nous regarde pourquoi le préfet il y
a des sciences de justice pourquoi
est-ce qu'il n'applique pas qu'est-ce
qu'il fout c'est une idée
il est pas le Prophète il va avoir le
truc voilà il va il va le faire avant le
31 j'espère grâce aux médias grâce aux
médias il y a pas de médias les préfets
bougent pas pourquoi parce que c'est
très simple c'est un dossier qui coûte 0
à l'état est-ce qu'il y a pas de courant
des militaires donc le préfet préfère se
dire moi j'ai pas de problème le
propriétaire me réclame rien je laisse
ces gens-là parce qu'il doit le reloger
il doit la reloger il faut trouver une
solution franchement il y en a pas le
problème c'est la crise du logement
c'est pas du tout la responsabilité de
ce genre la crise du logement ils sont
pas responsables de la crise du logement
dans le pays c'est ça le problème moi je
veux voir pour les conséquences je me
bats pas pour le droit au logement le
droit de préfet il n'a pas voulu
répondre évidemment
sachez-le voilà il exécute pas une
décision de justice donc voilà ça ne
respecte pas une décision de justice ça
c'est important de le rappeler
Nadia Nadia
nos équipes ont été au téléphone
l'occupante illégale du logement des
retraités elle a commencé
par nous dire qu'elle avait découvert
avec stupeur la médiatisation de cette
histoire écoutez
personnel à des bulletins de salaire ils
étaient fonctionnaires je ne dirais pas
combien il faut que je Ret je le sais
ils ont laissé cet appartement quelqu'un
de confiance j'avais signé un bail et je
ne vais pas les salir comme eux ils le
font parce que j'ai plus de difficulté
d'intégrité et surtout pour le respect
de ma vie c'est de mes enfants mais par
contre j'entends bien de me battre alors
voilà alors vous allez voir on a on a la
suite de la réaction de Nadia là la
première phase donc Nadia il nous
l'avait dit qu'elle travaillait que
voilà Gilles un invoque son enfant tout
de suite donc c'est vous allez voir
c'est pas fini justement
l'invoque après parce qu'elle dit que sa
fille aurait été très affectée en voyant
tous les messages sur les réseaux
sociaux au sujet de sa maman et on le
comprend sa fille voilà
exactement il peut rien écouter un
nouveau nez non plus
on a dit tu as vu tous les propos ce qui
cela ma fille est descendue vas-y
maintenant regarde ce qu'on dit Robert
ce qu'on dit ce soir
on verse là on a touché à quelqu'un
la dignité de ma fille et je vais
protéger jusqu'à là alors Nadia c'est
nous regarde moi j'ai rien compris bien
sûr il y a rien contre sa fille on a
touché à sa fille mais les plus mal
aujourd'hui c'est Pierre et Maryse ça
faut pas l'oublier Pierre et Marie ils
vivent dans un camping-car pierre il est
je vous dis très mal il y a eu des
pathologies très graves Maryse je l'ai
vu hier dans quel état elle était elle
prend énormément de médicaments je vous
lis Marie il faut vite agir parce que
Maryse là elle est vraiment au bout du
bout elle se elle prend des Prozac elle
nous l'a dit hier elle a gros la grande
dose parce qu'elle elle en peut plus
elle est voilà elle n'arrive plus à
vivre alors Nadia bien sûr on comprend
que votre fille qui n'a rien à voir
là-dedans forcément la médiatisation de
l'affaire ça puisse
responsable la responsable c'est vous
Nadia oui et puis c'est vrai que le fait
d'invoquer sa fille vous avez sans doute
le confirmer ça rend son expulsion
encore plus difficile enfant mineur
alors là il faut un relogement pour
qu'elle parte donc je trouve que je dis
ça à plat elle est très bien conseillée
parce que mettre en avant sa fille ça
lui permet de gagner un peu de temps
supplémentaire vous avez raison parce
que alors je vous dis juste non mais
d'après après on te l'air pas les
insultes et les menaces contre Nadia
contre sa fille voilà nous on a juste
envie que Nadia et je suis sûr que Nadia
elle a un cœur et qu'elle a vu l'état de
numériser Pierre et moi sa fille aussi
ça me fait de la peine pour ça je le dis
sans là que sa fille soit prise à partie
c'est inadmissible aussi sa fille peut
pas être prise à partie il faut trouver
un arrangement et vous allez voir ce
qu'elle nous dit après dans le prochain
audio on a déjà puisqu'on a la suite de
sa réaction oui c'est plus grave pense
que juste rester dans un appartement
elle paye plus le loyer donc si elle
était de bonne foi au moins le père et
le loyer et en plus elle ne paye même
plus l'eau c'est-à-dire que c'est la
double peine pour ces gens là qui
doivent en plus payer ses factures mais
c'est le monde à l'envers c'est elle qui
porte atteinte à la dignité de sa propre
fille vous allez voir ce que nous a dit
dans un instant juste là on voit que
Nadia pour l'instant on voit que elle
joue sur aussi avec sa fille soit soit
mineure a été jugé tout ça ça a été jugé
il y a le juge a apprécier les
situations une situation qui était jugée
normalement le lendemain et ben elle
doit partir c'est tout c'est mais c'est
quoi ça c'est on est donc on vit dans
quel monde d'expulsion
oui je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
Mathieu tu as pas vu l'histoire mais
bien sûr je la découvre je l'ai vu ce
matin que j'ai regardé mais
effectivement oui dans le monde de
Gilles dans le monde où effectivement
bah il faut comprendre les lois il faut
comprendre que c'est pas appliqué il
faut en discuter en discuter alors qu'à
moi faut arrêter de discuté la vérité
aujourd'hui c'est que il y a une dame
aujourd'hui qui elle effectivement
elle qui porte atteinte à dignité de sa
fille qui est responsable aujourd'hui de
deux personnes qui sont malades et un
préfet qui or la loi c'est hallucinant
et donc si on regarde le préfet est en
la loi c'est ça la vérité j'ai pas du
tout dit ça sur cette affaire
de toi en général depuis début septembre
et de toutes tes exemples d'aujourd'hui
alors justement compte tenu de l'ampleur
qui a pris l'affaire Nadia donc si vous
nous rejoignez à 20h52 en direct sur C8
on parle de ces retraités en camping-car
qui sont en camping-car à cause d'un
squat enfin d'une
occupante illégale Nadia qui avait donc
loué leur maison voilà et ils étaient
partis à l'étranger ils sont venus elles
ne payent plus depuis combien de mois de
loyer plus que ça je crois
que ce maintien depuis plus de 2 ans si
vous voulez ça fait très longtemps
qu'elle aurait dû libérer les lieux elle
a eu largement le temps de se reloger si
elle avait fait le nécessaire avant elle
aurait pu se reloger non pas les moyens
bien entendu prendre autre chose voilà
800 euros c'est énorme c'est énorme bien
sûr des mois et des mois sont payés moi
donc ils doivent payer l'eau aujourd'hui
ils vivent dans un camping-car
ils sont étrangler sachez-le il n'ose
plus voir leurs amis
j'ai vu Maryse je lui dis elle prend du
Prozac à tout va René il est Pierre il
est au bout de sa vie il je le voyais
c'est un amour de mec en plus vraiment
ça ça m'a ça m'a fondu le cœur comme à
vous tous d'ailleurs vous étiez très
nombreux à nous suivre hier soir et
compte tenu de l'ampleur qui a pris la
ferme Nadia nous a dit ceci
bon je vais juste prendre peut-être mes
albums photos de mes bébés parce que
j'ai rien je vais prendre mes photos
quelques vêtements à ma fille sur les
clés et on a fini là je pense
mais ça ce serait magnifique parce que
voilà la limite voilà même si elle
pouvait partir au plus vite Nadia après
bien sûr on ne souhaite pas de malheur
on a peut-être on espère qu'elle va
retourner un logement qu'elle va enfin
elle travaille et on pense à savoir le
préfet normalement doit lui se trouver
une solution d'hébergement c'est aussi
pour la responsabilité de l'État ça il y
a pas d'expulsion sans relogement
normalement dans notre pays normalement
faut la reloger
les personnes alors la préfecture
exactement très bonne question il y a
pas de solution non mais dans leur
camping-car en attendant
avril elle a eu le temps de se préparer
pour partir à la pas pu partir admettons
après il y a une décision au mois de mai
du lycée qui lui a dit de quitter les
lieux au mois de mai toujours pas elle
veut toujours pas le 14 septembre la
décision allait tomber la 14 septembre
elle devait partir et devait quitter les
sauf que c'est le préfet qui doit
déclencher ça et le préfet ce matin il
nous dit que c'était prévu qu'il fasse
là dans la semaine moi je dis qu'ils
vont la reloger très vite et tant mieux
ils vont récupérer leur camping-car
parce que on espère que passer à BFM et
et à Touche pas à mon poste c'est fini
le préfet il est obligé de bouger là il
peut pas rester caché on pourra pas
traiter tous les cas libéré le problème
c'est pas un débat c'est parce que c'est
pas ça vous soumettre si vous voulez
merci en tout cas merci d'avoir été avec
nous romain aussi vous l'avez vu
peut-être ce sont des bonnes nouvelles
parce qu'elle a dit qu'elle allait
quitter le logement donc ce serait une
très bonne nouvelle